make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and welcome back to comics explained
a youtube channel where i will make you
a comic book expert in 30 minutes or
less and in this video i'm going to make
you an expert on the origin of the
eternals now here's the reason why i say
the origin as opposed to like the
eternals explained the reality
is that the eternals as a race as a
group are not particularly interesting
outside of their origin their origin is
super cool and especially like when you
get to the titanos war that's really
really amazing
but in terms of the the nature of the
eternals and like their publication
history what they have to do with like
humanity different things like that
we would be much better suited to cover
the origin of the eternals and then go
into individual characters right icarus
explained
cersei explained different things like
that even like gilgamesh explained right
we could do those things
individually and it would really i think
provide a more comprehensive explanation
to the eternals as opposed to trying to
cram what little history there is after
the titanos war
into like this this whole video right so
this really goes back to what's called
the first host of the celestials now for
those of you guys who don't know what
that means
the celestials as you may or may not
know are basically like this
this race of space gods now their origin
has been retold over and over and over
again and more recently it was retold in
alewing's ultimates which if you never
read that it's an amazing story it
basically deals with like the universal
and multiversal avengers it's really
really really really cool
but the the long and short of this is
regardless of how their origin
unfolds their role largely stays the
same and the the role that the
celestials played is that they would
travel across the universe and they
would experiment
on the citizens of different planets
across the universe
one of the most notable examples of this
that predates humanity are the scrolls
now what you have with regards to the
scroll mythos is what's called deviant
scrolls and i'll talk about what it
means when i say deviant here in a
minute but largely the scrolls were
essentially a warlock race because the
deviants are a warlike
group uh this ended up leading to them
becoming a peaceful race and expanding
across the universe and then they came
across the creed and the cree eventually
initiated a war with the scrolls and the
scrolls became warlike again and the two
groups just been fighting each other
ever since right so it's called the cree
scroll war and and while it officially
did have an end date it's really more of
a ceasefire
than anything else and the two groups
really hate each other that ran all the
way up to the events of empire
where they actually united into a
singular empire and it's just kind of
been following that form ever since how
long that'll last
i really have no idea but to get back on
topic here the celestials ended up
arriving on earth and when they did
they basically met up with a woman by
the name of gaia now gaia was presented
to us in marvel comics as essentially
mother earth or mother nature if that's
what you want to call her the sentience
of all flora and fauna across the planet
and what she did is she grabbed a group
called the wonderers and the wanderers
were really kind of
this like missing link between primate
man and modern man
and what gaia did is when she took the
wonders she presented them to a
celestial by the name of
gamadon the gatherer and what this guy
did is he broke the wonderers into
thirds
the first third went to xeron the tester
who basically destabilized their genes
so
he kind of created unchecked mutations
and these came in the form
of a grotesque physical appearance
enhanced strength the ability to top in
a tap into some kind of
cosmic energy potentially but basically
they went forward as the deviants
following that the second third was
given to a guy named nazar the
calculator
and this guy basically gave this group
of wonders or this the second third the
ability to tap into
pure cosmic power and then provided them
with a kind of angelic appearance and
they became the eternals
the third group was given to oneg the
prober and what he did is he planted
what was referred to as a latent gene
which manifested in a couple different
forms
marvel uses this idea to explain why it
is that people like steve rogers can be
injected with a super soldier serum and
then be exposed to vitarase and instead
of dying from radiation sickness
become captain america or bruce banner
can be exposed to gamma rays and instead
of him dying of radiation sickness he
can become
the incredible hulk same thing with
spider-man peter parker different
characters like that
this was also used to explain the
arrival of mutants that this latent gene
was basically the x gene
and that during moments of high stress
or usually during times of puberty
that these genes would activate and
people would suddenly gain extraordinary
powers
and so for the eternals themselves when
the the first host basically
left earth the eternals were tasked with
the role of safeguarding humanity
against the deviants due to the warlike
nature of the deviants the issue with
this is that almost immediately after
the eternals
were really kind of you know tasked with
this role and the celestials left you
ended up getting something that was
called the titanos conflict and the
reason why it's called this is because
the eternals
basically established a city for
themselves that was called titanos but
you ended up having these two
individuals who went to war against one
another
the first one was uranus and the second
one was kronos now uranus believed that
because of the power
of the eternals that they were the
rightful rulers of earth and they should
have
they should basically abandon the role
given to them by the the celestials and
they should just
conquer the entirety of the planet
kronos was far more peaceful and
believed
that should not be the case and so again
this civil war emerged between these two
factions where you had one group that
wanted to conquer the world and the
other one who didn't now ultimately
orenos was defeated and his followers
lost the will to fight and this led to
oreno's and what few followers were the
most loyal to him and didn't defect to
the side of kronos being banished from
earth now this also
devastated the population of the
eternals and really led to to their
population being reduced to a tenth of
what it previously was now for uranus
himself
he actually ended up taking to space and
then basically with his followers
plotting his revenge against kronos
ultimately he settled on titan but then
eventually they engaged in a civil war
of their own which pretty much wiped out
the entirety of their remaining
population with the exception of a woman
by the name of sui-san but back on earth
kronos had basically beseeched his sons
to essentially never wage war against
each other
the problem with this is that it was
believed that somewhere along the line
war would be inevitable just the nature
of eternals and really just the nature
of humanity at their baseline
and so in order to prevent this war from
potentially breaking out that the sons
of of kronos ended up splitting up and
so
zuros stayed on earth to lead the earth
eternals and alars took to
saturn's moon titan to create his own
faction of eternals that resided there
alars ultimately met sui san and then
they had two sons
the first one went on to become the
superhero star fox and the second one
went on to become the villain
thanos and so that's where thanos comes
from in marvel comics those you guys who
aren't really familiar with that
back on earth in the aftermath of the
the war of the eternals this coincided
released a conclusion shortly after that
coincided with the second host of the
celestials who had basically arrived to
kind of check up on their experiment and
see how it was progressing when they
arrived on earth they were pissed
because they realized the eternals
because of their war had basically
abandoned the role that they were they
were assigned by the celestials this led
to the deviants essentially
taking over the the surface world or
taking over the earth and then enslaving
humanity
and so when the celestials arrived and
they tried to stop the deviants the
deviants attacked the celestials and so
the celestials initiated what was called
the great cataclysm where they
essentially sank the uh
the kingdom of atlantis which was home
to the to the deviants where they had
their capital city of lumeria and so
what deviants remained
ended up going underground the eternals
were warned if they failed to
to maintain their role that the the
celestials would destroy what was left
of the
the eternals they would cleanse the
earth entirely and they would start all
over again and so humanity basically
became the dominant species on earth
with the deviants residing underground
and the eternals staying on the surface
and then actually outlying themselves
with the greek gods so like zeus hera
and those individuals and then just kind
of keeping an eye on humanity and just
watching their progress
and protecting them for whatever you
know extra terrestrial threats or even
earth-based threats may come from them
or the or the deviants now this
eventually led into what was called the
third host when the celestials arrived
yet again
to not only check up on their experiment
but to ensure the eternals were
maintaining the role that had been
assigned for them but in seeing the
eternals had allied themselves with the
greek gods and the greek gods
through the eternals and even of their
own volition were involving themselves
in the affairs of men so like zeus
showing up in a greek city and like
sleeping with a girl and then having
hercules right or even odin
uh from the norse mythology getting
involved with humanities affairs
thor being a superhero on earth not
really a superhero in the traditional
sense we're basically operating on earth
loki doing some mischievous stuff balder
doing his thing
it led to the the celestials coming to
the realization that the
the involvement of this this group of
sky fathers could in effect
alter the course of humanity's uh
experiment and basically ruin what it
was the celestials
were looking to achieve and so this led
to the celestials basically forcing
uh the sky fathers to stay hands off and
this was marvel's explanation for why it
was that like odin
and zeus and all those guys were
constantly involved in what humanity was
doing and then suddenly stopped one day
at the same time it was also realized by
the eternals that if they ever went to
war with the deviants because the groups
were kind of taking pot shots at each
other here and there that if they ever
engaged in a full-on war it would lead
to the destruction of both of their
races which inevitably would lead to the
destruction of the world and so this led
to a truce between the deviants and the
eternals where they largely stayed hands
off with each other and so following
that you basically go into the future
endeavors of the eternals
running all the way up until the modern
day but again the problem with this is
there's not a whole lot known
about their various deeds and the kind
of escapades they got involved in the
truth is that the story of the eternals
largely focus on icarus or cersei or
people like that
we do know that that at some point in
the past about 5
000 years ago there was an eternal by
the name of gilgamesh who allied himself
with people like hercules
with people like achilles things like
that we knew that he was essentially a
guy who ended up ruling
a kingdom in samaria and then had a
daughter by the name of cersei who ended
up going forward and doing her thing but
there's not a whole lot known about what
they were doing during these these you
know historical periods
in in world history uh we really just
kind of have these small little moments
here and there
and then ultimately pick up with like
the modern era where the eternals are
doing things and that's why i say
we're better suited covering the origin
of the eternals here and then in a
future video
going over like icarus explained and
cersei explained and gilgamesh explained
and different things like that and kind
of covering these these characters
individually so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you